hi everyone it is my great honor today
to join today's uh
led blue webinar to share some of our
recent studies
on the pdl1 guide cancellation and the
cancer immunotherapy
hopefully through this presentation we
will have an idea
how we translate basic research to the
clinical use
in a hope of benefit patient at the
bayside
cancer immunotherapy has drastically
reshaped the thanksgiving of cancer
treatment
since the development of anti-ctla4
antibody in treating myeloma in 2010.
today there are over 500 clinical trials
total of nine type of monoclonal
antibody
developed by a pharmaceutical company
are currently
tested at a clinical site
in treating 20 type of cancer on
over 20 000 patients
so today our objective
is to first understand the new challenge
of breast cancer therapy our lab has
tremendous interest
in study this type of disease for two
decades
we have also like to take this
opportunity
to advocate that there is a spatial need
for the breast cancer patient to be
continued
breast cancer research to be continually
support
because the breast cancer mortality
it wasn't like 20 or 30 years ago breast
cancer was so devastating
since the development of hormone therapy
or target therapy
the mortality of breast cancer has
significantly reduced
so now the night 5 year survival rate is
over
90 so indicate that in
past 10 20 years scientists do achieve a
greater
advance on treating this type of disease
however these diseases still
have a lot of issue such as recurrent
metastasis or drug resistance so
therefore we still
would like to take this opportunity to
continuously
advocate for the patient that there is a
tremendous need for federal government
for philanthropists
for basic research to focus on this type
of disease
and second we would like to introduce
what we have been finding in the past
three years
we focused on a guy calculation of ptl1
and we translated this study to uh
immunotherapy
strategy development so we would also
touch base on that
to tell you how we identify
fungus of this important regulatory
mechanism and lastly i would like to
briefly introduce some of the new
technology we developed in the past
three years in
by working with ethan bioscience we
developed several
state of odd type of methodology
to try to help us to understand about
of science and try to translate this
research
to clinical use
first breast cancer
as i just mentioned is not has been
tremendous
treated in the past 20 years
so however american cancer cell cancer
society
still estimates that in the 2016
the new case identified in the woman
there will be 29
of the patient is will be identified as
the
breast cancer so this address rider
although the mortality has dramatically
reduced
for this disease however the incident of
this disease
still very high so therefore we as a
basic scientist we still have a lot of
room try to improve the treatment
or the quality of the breast cancer
patients
one type of breast cancer of our
interest
is called triple negative breast cancer
this type of list of type of breast
cancer lacks of
estrogen receptor progesterone receptor
and the human
epidermal growth factor receptor too
because this type of disease laid out a
treatment
target such as above mentioned the three
molecule
so therefore there is basically
no treatment for this type of disease
patient diagnosis with triple negative
usually
goes through the traditional
chemotherapy
unfortunately only half of the patient
can benefit from this therapy
which means another half of a triple
negative breast cancer
has basically no drug to cure
so to our interesting we found out that
in the among old breast cancer type
subtypes triple negative breast cancer
has the most abundant tumor infiltrated
lymphocyte this lymphocyte pre-present
in the tumor
supposed to help us to against the
cancer growth
but somehow this treat this triple
negative breast cancer has the mechanism
to to silence who
uh in activated lymphocyte inside the
tumor area so this also gives us a hint
that in the triple negative breast
cancer if we use the immunotherapy
to reactivate tumor cyto
lymphocyte activity will be a new
therapeutic strategy
to enhance the triple negative therapy
today
one of the most important immuno
suppression mechanism
has been identified is called pdl1
and the pd1 signaling exercise
so the next slide
showing you is a working mechanism of
this molecule
so as you can see on the panel a
the cartoon shows by the tumor cell
has the expressed a lot of tumor antigen
is exposed by the english c1 class
on a cell service and this
presentation once the t-cell recognizes
this presentation jesus can just say
well t-cell will come into the tumor
area
and try to eradicate eliminate this
cancer cell
rapidly however cancer cell is also
very small they will express the pdl1
on the cell surface this expression will
engage with the p-cell on the pe-1 and
this engagement
will will eventually
shut off the t-cell activity called
immuno escape
scientists now have developed monoclonal
antibody
that can specifically recognize either
pdl1 on the cancer cell
or pd1 on the t cell this type of
strategy will help to mask the
inclination surface of these two
molecules
and therefore flock this pel1 and the
pdy engagement
in an effort to reactivate the t cell
activity
allowing t cell to recognize the cancer
cell
and then eliminate
this fluorine substance
today this type of immunotherapy has
reached a
tremendous improvement
focus mostly on the melanoma hodgkin's
lymphoma lung cancer kidney cancer
and bladder cancer and there are four
drugs that have been approved by the fda
currently
is available and there are another five
drugs
that is under clinical trial right now
all targeted under pblind
pdy signaling accesses assets
then the overall response rate of this
type of
treatment is around 20 to 40 percent
kangman side effect including diarrhea
joint pain autoimmune disease
have been found but those are mild
and can be managed by steroids
and right now there are more and more
questions
such as intrinsic and acquire resistance
hyperquest progressive disease and try
to identify new biomarkers to precede
the
response of the anti-pbr1 pd1
is a new challenge that awareness to
study
so as i mentioned earlier triple
negatives
has inside the triple negative breast
cancer there is a lot of
infiltrated t cell and however tensor
cells still grow
so therefore we suspect that can triple
negative breast cancer must have
some kind of immunosuppression mechanism
so one molecule of interest is pdn1
this protein is placed on the cancer
cell
and is supposed to have molecular weight
33 kilo thousand
so as a cancer biologist
what we first like to do is to monitor
to test where the the pdl1 expressed
in the cancer cell line
so in the panel a we can see that of
course
breast cancer myeloma lung cancer
and the colon cancer cell lysate we feed
the
simple wastes of blood we try to
recapitulate the pdly expression on the
waste and block
and we found that this protein of
expression at the molecule a33 is very
little
so we have tried several ways to enrich
in this expression
but it was not very successful so in
lifetime
we actually uh interestingly we noticed
above the medical rate 50 kilo thousand
there is a huge abundant result
non-specific expression of the pda1
because the molecular weight is totally
wrong
and it expressed as a heterogeneous
expression
is not a distinct pattern that we used
to
expect on the regular western blot
so we didn't pay much attention in
lifetime here we use the over expression
system
with this way this installment we did
is we all we cloned the 33 kilo thousand
pdl1
and we expressed this protein in the 293
cells
we found out again there is no
33 kilo thousand protein expression
breaking under wasted blood
instead there is a 50 ml
kilo daughter molecule well pdawn
expression
we made several contra and they they all
seem to
act similarly so therefore we start to
suspect whether these
50 kilo data molecular weight of the
protein
of the signal is actually the pda1
to confirm this result we
and we found out that 50 molecular
weight kilo thousand
signal was disappeared when we
re introduced
returns to the wild type pdl1 into those
not on call we found out the medical
wave 50
kilodalton signal was reappeared
we also create another two crisper case
pipe case knife
knockout of pdl1 and we've completely
found out
that the molecular weight vpo dalton
is disappeared so this this result
suggests that this
high molecular weight of the protein is
real
pdline signal
again like i earlier mentioned our lab
has tremendous interest in study triple
native breast cancer
so what does this pdl1 express
in the breast cancer in this
slide we also use the panel of
breast cancer cell line and we group
them into
non-triple negative and the triple
negative breast cancer cell knife
and we did a simple waste of blood with
egfr
and the pdl1 egfi is highly expressed in
the pe
triple negative breast cancer which has
been known
and the pdl1 expression also
shows very high abundant inspiration at
a molecular weight 50
whereas the molecule is 33 kilo thousand
here in the red arrow we don't see much
expression
then we look for the literature to see
what might be the reason
costa the molecular weight shifter of
the pdl1
so what can come to our mind is that the
protein guy calculation
might cause the cell
molecular weight migration dramatically
so protein guy constellation
is the attachment of sugar moiety on
the protein to the glycol protein
it usually occur approximately at
predominantly either unext motif
unstain for asparagine x
is any amino acid and the t
is throwning guy calculation usually
happens in the
er and the golgi apparatus and
it is estimated that approximately
one-third
of all human protein has this type of
modification they are either unlinked
o-link or c-linker guy calculation
die castlation can choose protein
floating
localization interaction and enzyme
activity
so next we would like to know whether
while we observe the molecular weight 50
of the peli is
real that is really cut
through guy calculation so in this
experiment
we did is uh we overexpressed different
tags
of the pdl1 in this case
we have midtech at c terminal we have
flat tech
headed g terminal and we create another
x-ray attack at n-terminal we over
expression
this construct and then treat the cell
with tunica my thing
tunica my thing is a type of
chemical that can block unlinked guy
calculation synthesis
so we found out when we increase the
concentration of tunica mic
the molecular weight 50 of the pdl1
start to decrease
to molecular weight 33 kilodalton
so these results suggest the of
the pda1 is a highly calculated protein
we got it uh as long as we use the
overexpression system
and or when we look at endogenous
table
so next we would like to know where does
this guy calculation happen
so next we do the uh
we checked the mouse pbl1 and the human
pbl1 sequence
we found out there are four xt motifs
consensusly uh found out in the
extracellular domain of the pdl1 they
are
uncertified a knight 192
n200 and n219
so therefore to understand
which side involved in this this guy
calculation in vein
we first create single mutation on the
pdf one
and we consistently see that all four
single mutation has ability to
reduce the protein migration of the pda1
so then we continuously create double
mutant and a triple newton
pda01 migration was continuously
reduced here we created a 41q
when we complete we will take four guide
calculation
psi we found our pdl1 expression goes to
molecular weight
33 kilo dollar and as i showed you
earlier
that wild type pbl one treated with two
nita myosin
also caused nungai and reduced to
non-gaia carcinogenic
so in this case we can see a nice
side-by-side
together with these two molecules
which suggests that pel1 is only
glycosidic
at least four sites we also
create another three asparagine mutants
as a non-extreme motif and they do not
change any molecular shift of the pdl1
so on the left side we did a mass
spectrum analysis
collaborate with the academic cynical in
taiwan
we identified this uncertified
the guy construction of this uncertified
td l1
of course we also identified the the
other guy constructor and
because of the space issue we are not
going to show you
here today
since pdry is highly calculated so the
next
we would like to know is whether this
fork
guideline structure will affect its
interaction with pd1
to do this we first do a
set of in visual binding system
in this case we over expression flat tag
pdl1
in the cell and we use the flag b to
pull down this flat tag
pp l1 and then in q incubate
with anti so incubate with pd1 protein
in the solution and after that we did a
product experiment
we found out that the wild type td l1
can interact with pd1
efficiently however when nung
calculator pda1 do not interact with pd1
to test these hypotheses in vivo
we use a inquisite a lifetime
imagery system to quantify the dynamic
change between pdl1 and pd1
so the in the first
picture we show in the red color this
bt549 cells
has a nuclear ip spreadsheet
and then this cell will also express a
wild type pdl1 which is a guide cast
form of the pdl1
and then we add a fluorescence labeled
pd1 protein in the solution
after 12 hours of time
we can measure the dynamic interaction
between
p e l1 and pd1 so as you can see that uh
there is a huge accumulation of red
color on the cell surface
after 12 hour uh treatment
and on the other hand in the non guy
custard ptl one stable core
we don't see any much p uh green
fluorescence
suggests pdl1 and pd1 do not incline
after 12 hour period
so here we show you three individual
chrome
they all act similarly which we
consistently support
with our individual data show that this
guy construction
is required for protein protein
interaction
so to understand the function of this
uh guide calculation we did a
we did a t-cell killing asa
so in this experiment again we use a
inquisite machine
to make to mimic the dynamic
of interaction the cell growth of the
cancer cell and the
in the presence of t cell so in this
case it's a bt 509 uk ip call
and we add a cytota activated the t-cell
incubate together for about five days of
time
and we can see the reinforcements which
indicate a
case phase three activity as soon as a
cancer cell starts to
die we will see the reduce of the red
color
and also the gain of the wind
supporations
and this quantification tells us that
indeed
guy constellation custody the pda1
cancer cell has the ability to resist to
t
cell kidney whereas nungy calculator is
very sensitive to
t-cell kidney
next we perform the in vivo experiment
to confirm this result
by the inaugural 4t1 pdl1 wildtype and
the pdl1
nungai calculator pda1 and then into the
babchi mouse
we found out at two weeks of time there
is a huge geometrical regress
differences between these two columns
suggest that the
loss of the guide calculation the tensor
cell blows out
its ability to suppress g cell activity
and we also did a functional analysis
try to
understand what's the difference between
dicosa data flow and the non-guy
calculator pdl1
so in this case we do the cyclohexami
post-stress
experiment we found that the wild type
pd guy calculator pdr1 is very stable
whereas non-guide calculator pda1 the
half-life is very short and the two
systems all indicate the same phenomenon
so next we would like to know what the
option signalling that regulates this
guy calculation event so what we did is
we took
two triple native breast cancer cells bt
509 and uh
for 68 cells and we treat with the
different simulator
such as egf igf htgf fogf and the tgf
data
we found consistently egf can induce
pdl one guy calculation in two triple
native breast cancer
because egf is a ligand of egfr so we
also confirm this result by adding
different type of egfr ligand and we
found that
as long as eg egfr being activated
the pda1 expression also increased
and the left a right panel shows you the
cell
the first cytometry major the membrane
bound the pdl1
is being upregulated by egf ligand
so lastly we would like to use this
model to conclude our finding
that egfr has the ability to
stabilize pdl1 because non-dicastical
pdl1
will be recognized by the gsk3 beta and
thereby recruit a beta trcp to degrade
this pdl1 protein
once pd l1 giga calculated
it will prevent the gsk3 beta where can
recognize the pdl1 and therefore cause
the immunosuppressor activity
and lastly since our signaling analysis
indicate that egfr
is the one of the key signaling that
induced pd a one guy calculation we
suspect that
egfr if we use a calcium kinase
inhibitor to inhibit egfr
will be able to downregulate pdl-1
expression
in the cancer cells so the here is the
flow chart that we perform this animal
analysis
by treating everyday uh every day
daily with the geneva and also every
three days we treated with
100 micrograms of antipede one antibody
and we found out the combination of
these two therapy
significantly reduce the tumor growth of
the
41 mile cells
and this mouse has increased
has increased the mouse survival about
20
by combining these two therapies we also
look at the
uh the teal analysis uh
inside the tumor area which is a cd3
cda positive we look at the interferon
gamma expression
and consistently combining these two
therapy
enhanced dramatically interferon gamma
sequential
and also we look at the green enzyme
activity
found out that the tumor area that uh
when we combine these two treatments the
brain dynamicity of the
cancer cells can be activated
so conclusion of this the first part of
my talk is that
we found pdl1 is unlinked guy calculated
either for an xt motif
gsk3 beta can force foiling and
destabilize
non-guide cascade pbl1
and guide calculation can stable like
pdl1
should prevent gsk3 beta binding to
sungai cascade pda1 and the uptrend
signaling
is the egf that can increase the
non-carcass data for our pdl1 so
if we combine uh you inhibit
the egfr signaling we are able to
synthesize
painter's triple native breast cancer
cell to n-type pd-130
in the synagogue syngenic animal model
next i would like to quickly switch
here to show you one of the our another
finding
we also incorporate a lot of methodology
using the
ethan bioscience into side microscope
and we have published another paper in
the kansas cell 2016
so what we found is that a triple
negative
is also a will also induce a chronic
inflammation
so we would like to know what's the
information
why this information can cause cancer
progression
so we found that inside the tumor micro
environment
microfiber has the ability to secrete
the tna for alpha
and this tlf file will recognize uh
tensor cell tma5 are receptor
so in this enlarged cartoon
on the right side the underlying
mechanism
is that the tnf fiber will activate
unless kapha b
and cause the p-65 nuclear translocation
and thereby turn on the csm5 expression
and we identified that cssi is a novel
the u-b-cretination enzyme
and this enzyme will stabilize pdl1
and therefore translocate induce the
cancer cell immunosuppression function
so in the end we found in this
study that doing in the tumor micro
micro environment the three cell two
immune cell
microphos and the t cell and how these
three cells interact
together in the tumor micro environment
related to the immunosuppression
activity
next i would like to spend some time to
also discuss
our recent study that we work with the
htq
pharmaceuticals we try to
identify the first
antigua calculator antibody as we showed
you earlier
that triple negative has very high
abundant expression
of the sky cascade pdl1
so we are wondering if we can generate
antibody
that can specifically target this for
the structure of the pdl1
we may generate more therapeutic impact
so in this regard what we did is
we inoculate guy calculator pdl1
as an antigen into the mouse and then we
create three thousand hyperdoma chrome
so then next we use a full phytometry
to screen those three thousand clones
try to look for the antibody
that can specifically recognize
guy calculated pda1 but not non guy
casting the pda1
and then we use the inquisite
machine to help us to further narrow
down
which antibody has the ability to
neutralize
pdl1 and pd1 interaction
we finally narrowed down two mono
coronal antibodies that has stability
so this is a slide showing you that the
stm10004 at the spm108 antibody
these two antibodies has a very profound
effect in inhibiting
pdl1 the pd1 interaction
so next we would like to know where does
these two antibodies
bind to the pdl1 guideline structure so
in this case
we create
a three an xt motif
mutation and we keep one in this case is
uncertified as a wild type
and we keep individual glycan cell
diacon structure as a wild type
and then we did a simple waste and blood
we found out that stm10a antibody
can specifically recognize on 192 and
200.
and we based on our earlier my special
analysis
we already know that there is a very
unique guidance structure appear on this
uh
n192 and n200 which are the two sides
that can be recognized by our
stm1ua antibody
because earlier studies show that
guy calculation of the her2 has the
ability to
cross-link the membrane boundary too and
therefore
induce classroom dependent her2
internalization
so this paper help us to
hypothesize that whether these are our
antibody
antigua calculated pda1 antibody also
have the ability
to cross link a membrane bound pdl1 and
therefore
induce this pdly internalization
and goes to the lysosome and
further get equated in the cells so to
do this
we incorporate with
ethan bioscience technology and also
with the ph rotor system
to do this we for reasons label our
stm12a antibody with a fluorescent style
and one this uh so the theory is that
when the cell starts to uptake this
antibody
this the ph value will
start from the membrane which is ph
7 drop to the ph 4.5
inside the lysosome and this acidic
condition
will help the linker region of the
antibody
to decorate once this linker region get
relief
you will luminance for reforestance
in the microscope so in this case
we are able to use a inclusive lifetime
imagery system
to measure the fluorescence
reference references and also
uh in the real time we can take the
picture how
and where the reformations appear
so in this case we can see in 12 hour
period of time
when we add the stm100a antibody
into the bt509 stable chrome we can see
very nice restorations induced suggests
that
htm10a antibody can specifically
internalize into the painter scale
and once it internalized
we can see we did a waste and block and
this was done in the fight after five
days of treatment
we can see that significantly among of
the pdl1
is reduced suggests that this antibody
has the ability to internalize pdl1
and further degrade the pda1
so why this internalization and the
degradation is
so important because recently we there
is a
antibody drug conjugation technology
that is available so we are thinking
whether we can take this advantage
to conjugate a cytotoxicity drug
into the our antibody so in this case we
choose the
ae as our warhead and
we conjugate in our conjugation
on average there are four chemo drugs
being conjugated on our antibody
so we test the efficacy of this antibody
in the visual and also in vivo
we found out that the old leader cell
has the
pdl1 expression can specifically be
treated by its antibody this is
in vivo and here
when the mice has a pdly expression
their tumor growth after treatment with
our adc is dramatically reduced
so this is the 41 human pbelon stable
chrome
they do not grow after we treat with
our dicastical
adc antibody so this result is very
exciting
so we also look at the tumor micro
environment to see that using the
fluorescence ihg staining to detect
the case activated the case phase three
activity
so in this case in the red color
indicator
case-based reactivity when the mice
treated with guy calculator
ae antibody we can create
a geometrical case page 3
activation in the tumor micro area
we also did a
site of analysis we found that
nice treat with the guy calculated an
ae antibody has dramatically
tumor cell reduction but likely the
immune cell get infected
so these results suggest that this
antibody can selectively
selectively target the cancer cell but
not
in new cells because as i mentioned
earlier
that guy constituted of pdl1 is highly
abundant
in the triple native breast cancer cells
so lastly i would like to use this model
to summarize this part of our study
which is that egfr is
the major signaling that can induce
some sort of glycotransferase induction
and these glycol transfers will further
dicaster pdl1 and then
that this pdf1 goes to the cell membrane
if we can create the antibody line
specifically
recognized calculated pda1 will have
ability to
induce this pdl1 f13 and also
once this endocytosis even happens
it will go to the lysosome and then get
degraded
once the antibody and the pda one get
degraded
the cancer cell cycle toxicity drug will
be relieved
and then to kill the pdl1
high expression cell and also create a
bystander effect
which will eradicate the cancer cell
that do not express pdl1
so this will create a profound
therapeutic
effect in reducing re eradicating
triple negative breast cancer
so the conclusion what we found
throughout
this study is that a guy calculation is
a very
complex structure and
it's very difficult to assess in the
regular basic research lab so
in this regard guy calculation is often
being neglected
so based on our signaling analysis
we can design and design
a so a strategy
and then try to isolate monoclonal
antibodies like can
specifically recognize dicaprio pbl1
and we first found out that hpdl1
can cause link membrane boundary el1
so pdly antibody can cross-link anti
a pdo molecule and and therefore
induce the endocytosis of this protein
and through these endocytosis we can let
the antibody
to carry a cytotoxicity drug and then
induce a profound therapeutic impact to
breast
supernative breast cancer